you ever jealous of the love J had for
two oh
yeah oh my God that dude like and you
know that was in the that was in the
early days yeah that was in the early
days and it was like that was a big
regret for me too cuz I could never I
could never open up to interact with
with Pac you know and cuz we had a
little bit of a thing right because you
know you know they grew up together and
you know they loved each other but they
never had that you know they never had a
a sexual relationship but they had into
that age where now that was a
possibility and then Jada was with me
you know so you know Pac had a little
thing on that um but she just loved him
like he was the image of perfection but
she was with the Fresh Prince you know
so that was a huge regret of mine I just
didn't I couldn't I couldn't handle it
you know and how sad is that this guy
has accomplished all he's accomplished
and he still can't live up to the ghosts
of her past